Lo que haremos en este video es observar que
si tenemos dos triángulos diferentes -y tenemos
dos pares de lados correspondientes que tienen la
misma longitud, por ejemplo: este lado azul tiene
la misma longitud que el lado azul que tenemos
aquí y este lado naranja tiene la misma longitud
que este lado naranja, y tenemos dos ángulos
correspondientes aquí que se forman entre estos
lados y que también tiene la misma medida de modo
que tenemos un lado, ángulo, lado, lado, ángulo,
lado-, si estos tienen las mismas longitudes o
medidas, entonces podemos deducir que estos dos
triángulos son congruentes bajo la definición
de congruencia por transformaciones rígidas.
El criterio es que si tenemos lado, ángulo,
lado en común (por sus siglas en inglés) y el
ángulo está entre los dos lados, entonces los dos
triángulos serán congruentes. Para probar esto,
para hacer esta deducción, sólo tenemos que decir
que siempre habrá una transformación rígida si
tenemos un lado, ángulo, lado en común que nos
permitirá mapear un triángulo sobre el otro,
porque si hay una serie de transformaciones
rígidas que nos permiten hacerlo, entonces,
por la definición de transformación rígida,
los dos triángulos son congruentes. Así que
para empezar podríamos hacer referencia a
dos segmentos que tienen la misma longitud,
como el segmento AB y el segmento DE. Si
tenemos dos segmentos con la misma longitud
que son congruentes siempre se puede mapear un
segmento en otro con una serie de transformaciones
rígidas. Lo que podríamos hacer en este
caso es mapear el punto B sobre el punto E,
así que ahora tendríamos B' justo aquí. Si
hicimos una transformación para ver eso,
si sólo trasladamos el triángulo así, el
lado BA, este lado naranja, se vería algo así.
Pero luego podríamos hacer otra transformación
rígida que sería rotar sobre el punto E o B',
rotar este lado naranja junto con todo el
triángulo hacia DE, en cuyo caso, una vez
que hacemos esa segunda transformación rígida, el
punto A ahora coincidirá con D. O podríamos decir
que A' = B, pero la pregunta es: ¿ahora dónde está
C? Bueno, podemos ver la distancia entre A y C,
de hecho podemos usar nuestro compás para
eso. La distancia entre A y C es ésta,
y así como las transformaciones rígidas
preservan la distancia, sabemos que C',
que es el punto en el que mapearemos C después
de estas dos primeras transformaciones, va a
estar a la misma distancia de A', entonces C' va
a estar en algún lugar a lo largo de esta curva.
También sabemos que las transformaciones rígidas
preservan las medidas de los ángulos, y por eso
sabemos que a medida que hacemos el mapeo el
ángulo será preservado, de modo que el lado AC
podría ser mapeado sobre este lado que tenemos
aquí, y si ese fuera el caso entonces F = C,' y
habríamos encontrado nuestra transformación rígida
con base en lado, ángulo, lado, por lo tanto,
los dos triángulos serían congruentes. Pero
hay también la posibilidad de que el ángulo se
conserve pero el lado AC se mapee aquí abajo,
así que después de nuestro primer conjunto de
transformaciones rígidas hay otra posibilidad
de que el lado AC se vea así, se vería así.
En cuyo caso C' se mapearía justo aquí, y en ese
caso podemos hacer una transformación rígida más,
podemos hacer una reflexión sobre DE o sobre
A'B' para reflejar el punto C' para llegar
allí. ¿Cómo sabemos que C' se mapearía sobre
F? Bueno, este ángulo se preserva debido
a la transformación rígida, así que cuando lo
volteamos, mientras hacemos la reflexión sobre DE,
el ángulo será preservado y A'C' se mapeará sobre
DF. Terminamos, acabamos de demostrar que siempre
hay una serie de transformaciones rígidas
que pueden mapear un triángulo sobre otro,
siempre y cuando cumplan con estos criterios lado,
ángulo, lado, y por lo tanto son congruentes.